nikolai link anmelden
das sind ja gestimmt selten so gelacht
ich muss jetzt mit dir leider auf ein
etwas traurigeres thema zu sprechen
nämlich die gesammelten werke von herrn
meyer und was sie dir bedeuten
das heißt eigentlich aber ich kann
trotzdem überall
doch dann sind alle gleich sind alle
großartig darf ich jetzt was dazu sagen
bitte endlich platzte fall von mir aus
nicht ja okay also dann beenden wir den
clip an dieser stelle und du gehst herrn
meierhof besuch und meine literatur ist
es nicht das sind anekdotische sammlung
es ist sehr doppeldeutig es ist wirklich
wahnsinnig gut geschrieben auf plante
geschrieben aber das ist ja nicht
verboten
meine damen und herren seit ungefähr 40
minuten werden wir darauf dass nicolas
steiner eine lustige ställe in denen das
thema lesen und wenn ich dann immer
diese lustigen talkrunden sehe wo immer
alle ganz begeistert sind wie lustig und
charmant du schreibst die lustigsten
büchern die lustigsten und anderen
büchern die man sich nur vorstellen kann
der herr meier ruf ist auch so lustig
und charmant selbst und dann sitzt er da
und erzählt noch ein paar lustige
geschichten wenn ich irgendwas nicht
leiden kann sowohl bei leuten wie bei
büchern dann ist es der wunsch zu
gefallen alles ist so hahaha charmantes
ist so klaus gott für prosieben publikum
ja das natürlich immer mit diesen
zutaten lattemann hält wohl doch nicht
so was es verspricht beim zweiten lesen
danken weil ich habe wirklich selten in
meiner ganzen lektüre zeit so begeistert
bücher gelesen das ist eine typen parade
ohne ende
es gibt keine einfache sie haben wir
machen doch etwas unangenehm es wir
lesen cappella literatur und venedig zu
stellen
weil sie ganz offen darüber dass ich es
doch mal was lesen wo trotzdem jemand zu
tode kommt aber was ein auch auf stellt
was einem auch gute laune macht was
einem wieder sagt die welt ist gut es
ist alles nicht ganz so schrecklich und
so weiter was was also ja wenn du damit
happy für das bitteschön bitte bitte
sehr
dann nimm deine vier meinung weil ich ja
sei doch ecken oder wenn eines der
obligatorischen bilder meiner großmutter
beim baden auf lanzarote kam gleich über
gibt sich brand ich an mir vorbei
so jetzt aufhören kann es nicht mehr
aushalten
schluss damit
[Musik]